luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to the
ohio plan show powered by icon plus capital the
vc firm and as usual it is sponsored by block five
so you can actually get pretty amazing interest
rates um when you go to block five much better
than leaving your money in a bank um i think
across europe we have negative uh interest rates
right now so i've left a link in the description
and in i think if you're watching on twitter it's
in the comments area so um just hit that and then
you can check it out um also guys if you are
watching on youtube please don't forget to hit
the like button and subscribe so you never miss
any of these brilliant guests all right so today
we are just going to go for it we're talking about
the market um also talking about entrepreneurship
and building in this space so joining me today
is the co-founder and ceo of stacked crypto it is
bitcoin but joel how you doing i'm doing
good how are you thank you for having me
yeah it's great to have you i'm doing well
thank you it's been a while since we spoke
yeah we're i think i mean i i think that
we i had stacked i think at the time it
was called lunar it was pre alpha it was
we didn't even have a product out yet and
i think that was the last time we caught up
so it's been a it's been a long year or so
since then but man crypto it i know we were we
were right we were right i know and we've spoken
earlier and you were saying everyone is starting
to get rewarded but before we get into crypto and
everything all the nitty gritty bits um for those
that don't know who you are i know a lot of people
do but for those that don't please just give us
your background and tell me what you're doing yeah
uh no i imagine most people don't know who i am
um but you know before crypto i worked a lot in
traditional startups uh inside that ecosystem i
always really was obsessed with using technology
to solve problems i found myself early stage at
grubhub and spent a lot of years just learning how
to scale a tech business by working in leadership
leading restaurant growth at grubhub so at grubhub
and working in that startup environment i came
across bitcoin early on and was in 2015 was
kind of captivated and you know i like to say
the rest is history i quit my job in uh january
of 2018 so for those of us who were around
back then you remember that was the pico top
absolute best time to walk away from uh from a
nice perfectly well-paying job uh spent the next
18 months losing all of my money and a lot of my
hair um but continue to try to find ways to solve
problems um and ultimately you know i've i've been
a long time investor and enthusiast in this space
i've had my ups and downs with trying to trade
this market but all in all you know i'm i'm a
full-blown degenerate crypto enthusiast i love
jpegs i love bitcoin i love [ __ ] coins i love
can i say that i don't know all coins yeah yeah i
love you know the ups and downs i you know i love
to mess around um you know and have fun with with
leverage when i can and i like to be a long-term
passive hodler i'm a little bit of everything uh
and i've been operating a ceo of stacked now for
the last uh 18 months or so so you said that in
2015 you were captivated what got you well the
same thing that i think gets most people i'm not
going to sit here and you know try to bs about
it i needed well i didn't need i wanted to play
blackjack online and there was this particular
site that i won't give free airtime to but they're
still in operation today and they accepted crypto
and i knew what bitcoin was i just didn't care
about it um and so i bought bitcoin in order to
basically play blackjack on this website
it was three or four months later that um
that the market started to turn around i basically
bought the bottom i mean i bought bitcoin like
two hundred dollars in september 2015. so now
all of a sudden i see this this crap that is
just sitting in my gambling account go up in value
what captivated me well number go up captivated me
make money captivated me right like wow wait wait
a second what is this is this some new and then
down the rabbit hole i go i obviously got educated
on it as a as a technology in the restaurant yeah
so what always gets me is um people going full
time right because most people in this space
it's not actually their full-time job um right
but i know a lot of people want it to be and
you know people are always asking me how do you
go full time how did you do it so that must have
been really difficult leaving a nice comfortable
job i know obviously number go up makes you feel
like it's okay you can leave it keep going
um yeah but you but you left your full-time
job as the bear market set in and people don't
really know where we are right now in this market
so talk to me about leaving that full-time
job how did you even know where to go yeah
so i'm kind of a lifetime entrepreneur i've
always been fiddling around with technology
and trying to find ways to you know make money on
the internet i was drop shipping in 2006 on ebay
when i was um a senior in high school so i was a
long time ago right and so i've always been just
more interested in products and tech um and
like a lot the idea of like a lot of people
using something that i built then i have been
in you know money and so for me once i got to
a place where i realized that no matter what
happened with crypto from a price perspective
i was gonna have 12 months of my bills paid i was
comfortable enough to take that risk on myself
because i've always been an entrepreneur so i've
always been doing that sort of stuff i mean just
to get the opportunity at grubhub at the young
age that i did and move across the country you
know there was a whole story there so i'm i think
i'm good at taking risks i think if you're if
you're a trader if you if you're if your idea is
i'm going to quit my job to trade cryptocurrency
then you know i would refer to my good friends
uh don alt or crypto cred uh some of those guys
who have who have addressed exactly that and
what they'll say is listen if you've been trading
successfully with a track record in a journal
you know you know able to manage risk you have
12 months of reserves put away and you have a year
worth of actual trading underneath your belt and
you feel like you could take the next step who's
just i'm not you know good luck i wish you the
best but it is a loser's game for the most part
it it's one that pareto's principle definitely
applies and the majority of people 80 or so will
lose money um if they attempt to time the market
um so if you're trying to be a trader probably
don't quit your job unless you've done what i
just said if you're trying to build if you're if
you're an operator if you're a content creator
you know then the opportunities are endless in
this space take a risk on yourself go work for
a crypto company get paid in in [ __ ] coins and
hope they go up i mean there's so much opportunity
and i know you can attest to this if you just dm
somebody if you just meet someone at a conference
you just hop on a google chat you and i met
via dm a long time ago you've met countless
thousands of people since then just by networking
and that has opened up no doubt countless doors so
if you really love the space maybe go get a job
in this space you know there's plenty of companies
hiring including stacked free plug we are love
good um we'll get we'll get into all of it um
but yeah i think that that's such a good point
people just think that they can go and trade
they lose it all and then they never come back um
but yeah there are so many job opportunities in
this space um i think dming people is absolutely
the best thing to do i feel so done with emails
i don't know if it's you but whenever i get an
email which is an essay i'm just like uh no please
yeah yeah literally we're the generation
of the instant message you know telegram
discord slack text whatsapp that's how i
like to communicate as well just i am me
instant message me let's let's get going let's
move on and you know what that means that means
don't send an essay like email in a dm no it's
not just say say hey birch this is what i need
and then i'll either ignore you uh respond
with something that i need or out of the
goodness of my heart help you out depends
who you are but yeah shoot the dm over right
no i love it right so stack the hiring that's cool
so tell us about stacks for those who don't know
well yeah i would love to um stacked crypto on
twitter stacked is is the world's largest sec
registered automated investment advisor um in
crypto um essentially we are a platform that
allows you to put your portfolio on autopilot it
sits on top of your existing exchange you connect
your coinbase your ftx your ftx us your binance
account to stacked and it's a much more beautiful
and easy to use interface to manage your assets
swap lend coins on ftx with auto compounding
run trading strategies from some of your favorite
twitter traders that are out there that have bots
um you know all that sort of stuff and
recently we secured registration with the
sec so uh we're working on some new products
there that's yet to be announced but we're
working on some new stuff there as well so um
yeah automation platform for investing in crypto
so are there any exchanges right now let's say
like binance or ftx like that that provide that
automated service no and it ultimately it's not
their business that that's fine we're so new into
crypto that it's just inevitability before more
you know companies like mine are trying to come in
and service the 90 percent we talked about
pareto's principal like 47 seconds ago about how
most traders lose money that's kind of the thesis
behind stacked is that you shouldn't have to be a
day trader in order to be profitable long term in
the crypto space so we're looking to build tools
and user experiences that better help users adjust
their portfolios to their risk so that way they
can have a better user experience when investing
and they can be more long-term passive investors
i think you can probably attest to this the secret
to success financially and crypto for most people
is survival it's not catching tops and bottoms
it's not you know like if you if you catch one
great but it's not chasing and fomoing it's having
high conviction plays that you hold for extended
periods of time um maybe with some intelligent
dollar cost averaging or rebalancing like
different things that you can do to be more active
but if there's there's no doubt that huddling over
extended period of time historically has been
the best method so not trading has historically
been the best we just wanted to build a product
that helps you not trade better right like huddle
better and that's what stacked is kind of about so
it's not a trader's platform it's not for you to
go into all kinds there's already great platforms
for that uh ftx is my favorite but um if you're
looking for just a kind of a cool investment
experience in crypto stacks so from like a
practical and personal level because i i don't i
don't trade if i was to use stacks how how would i
go about it what value would it offer for me yeah
so again it's it's i i like to explain it like
this right let's say you hold money on coinbase
and let's say you hold currently 10 assets and
let's say you decide that you would like to move
half of all of your money into bitcoin or you name
it tether ripple whatever you're into if you're
like some kind of weird on you're into ripple
if you wanted to do that today obviously you would
have to log into coinbase go through that go into
each individual market you know for each one of
those assets sell a percentage of each one of
those things and that process can take upwards of
several minutes per coin if you're super efficient
but it's also tedious and it's also inefficient
and um it's not a very i don't know informative
user experience well if your coinbase account
is connected to stacked you can just log in
and move the slider for bitcoin to 50 and
stack will automatically sell whichever
assets you tell them you know unless you like
lock an asset and say don't sell this one
it'll rebalance your portfolio into 50 bitcoin
it takes 10 seconds it executes automatically
on coinbase your money is still safe in your point
you know wherever you know wherever you're holding
it um and it just makes the user experience better
so at the very top it's just a better way to move
money around it gets more granular from there like
buying pre-built portfolios like our sam bankman
freed basket which is the most popular one on our
website people connect their ftx account and they
invest in the sam bankman free basket we all love
sam and the basket is simply an equal weighted
basket of sushi serum ftt and solana which are
his four you know kind of pillar projects and
it rebalances automatically every 30 days it's
up i can't say like from a compliance standpoint
because i don't know the exact number but it's
up a lot over the last six and 12 months and so i
think a lot of users just like the ability to buy
a portfolio that's already kind of built for them
yeah no absolutely okay cool i'm gonna check
this out i love things which are just simple
easy and you can just explain it to me in the most
basic way like i'm not techy and to be honest i
don't think i think that's a good thing i don't
want to be techy that way hopefully i can like
put the message forward over to other people you
know we can actually improve the user experience
make things happen um but we're going to delve
into all of this guys remember joel is hiring
so drop him a dm no essays but drop him a quick
dmc's hiring so that's cool pretty much every
position you can imagine engineering damn that's
exciting marketing whatever okay cool that's cool
um all right before we delve further into that i
do want to talk to you about the markets because
things are looking very very interesting right
now um bitcoins at 62 thousand dollars which i
think is great um after that high you know i think
that's yeah that is just you know holding that and
not dropping down to 55 or anything like that is
really exciting but i'd love to get your thoughts
um well let's start off with understanding
were you surprised to see a new high no
um going back to the timing tops and bottoms
it's not my mo i was fortunate to sell around
may a large portion of my holdings into stables
and i was fortunate to buy a couple months later
just from market cycles but it wasn't tops
and bottoms it was just market cycle kind of
sentiment honestly cobain who i love on twitter
and you know as a friend um you know he kind of
called it perfectly and just kind of listening to
him and some of the other people we've mentioned
honestly it was just like back in may
was feeling very top-like now as a result
i missed some of the stuff that happened since
then i was not very exposed to the market and
there was a lot of upside in particular on the nft
space so i kind of slept on some of that and kind
of yeah you know i'm not claiming to be some kind
of prolific jpeg trader um but yeah that's been
like ultimately uh my experience but
the reason i started buying it back
in is because i said we're for sure retesting
what i'll tell you right now is and i've been
saying this for like the last month because as
being bitcoin birch obviously my in real life
friends and every you know they always want
to talk about crypto i have no freaking idea
i don't know if it's 100k i don't have 250k i
don't know if it's a million i don't know where
i just know like my conviction is that what you
see when you look at the bitcoin chart right now
is not what tops look like that's just my
conviction i survived the last top i've done
enough you know i've i've been exposed to enough
of the market enough of other markets i think
to at least have a high enough conviction play for
myself that this is not what tops look like and so
i'm not selling here personally you know um if
i'm wrong and things start to look really bad
maybe i'll change my mind i'll go on stacked i'll
move that tether slider up to 80 you know and just
start auto lending it on ftx through stacked um
in the you know in the next bear market but yeah
my price prediction is it's going to keep going
up so above here and so you know i continue to
like bitcoin what do you think caused this pump
you know forget like ta and tops and bottoms what
do you think cause it because also just you know
the crash as well i knew i remember i i put out
like an instagram story back in april and i was
just like i'm so sorry to tell you guys but i'm
just not bullish anymore i was like this feels
like a top but of course you had the china news
elon musk and that kind of just really tanked the
market so what do you think pumped it this time
yeah well sometimes nothing has to pump it um
you know it's just sentiment overall i think
you're going to continue to see correlation to the
u.s equities markets which rebounded in much the
same way um and have followed they're they're
relatively correlated at least lately at least
bitcoin is which the rest of the crypto market is
then also fairly correlated as we know the bitcoin
um so so i think a lot of it is just maybe overall
market sentiment being positive right now um you
know and ultimately the etf obviously doesn't
hurt right the the bitcoin etf is huge news
now those of us who are in the know understand
that it's kind of uh i think the word sub for
is a toxic product it's it's not a great product
but besides the point it is a toxic product yeah
it's not a great product but besides the point
it is a great media headline right and yes and
that media headline does bring people in who want
to buy and i think on top of that maybe more than
anything bitcoin has really solidified itself
as this like at least the narrative to bitcoin
is store value internet gold well people don't buy
gold with the intention of selling it the next day
and i so what i think you're starting to see
is the mindset of people buying bitcoin at
the retail level is more of you know i'm
just going to hold this i'm just going to
which is good by the way because i think that's
going to be a profitable endeavor for them
so i think you're just seeing more market
participation that's the technical answer
why does bitcoin go up well more people were
buying than selling that's why bitcoin went up
and so why were more people buying maybe etf
maybe it's because it was down 40 maybe it's
overall market sentiment maybe a combination of
all of those things yeah i'm totally with you i
think that um the narrative around bitcoin
matters and despite the crash that we had
it was the most bullish bear market you know you
have a country adopting bitcoin you have senators
you know speaking about it even yeah even even
twitter and strike um that is huge um you know
just so much going on um so yeah the sentiment is
the nft yeah nfts i actually think have a have a
flow over effect to the overall crypto market too
like obviously there's no bitcoin nfcs i shouldn't
say that i'm probably going home i'm sure there's
gonna be comment guys like there are bitcoin nfc
they're coming i think they're coming yeah
everything's on everything on ethereum right now
so everything's on here or solana where i'm really
enjoying nfts lately is on solana's protocol
i love my cavemen and my apes um but all that
to say the nft craze of the last especially a
couple months but really the last year has been
really driving a lot of participants into crypto
right it's been it's almost been that mainstream
event like the iphone was or really the ipod was
but the iphone was to the internet is what kind
of brought nfts are kind of starting to get a lot
of not like a lot of people more interested and
that's just a red pill and it's just opening the
door to more market participants so i do think
there's some flow over from the huge success
of nfts um and that market i think naturally
there's got to be spillover into well now that
i own this jpeg like what's this doggy maybe
i buy some bitcoin and so i think that can be
healthy too yeah no i'm with you i think that for
some unknown reason nfcs have gone so mainstream
um i i still don't know why they have um you know
you have the likes of gary vee talking about it
we've got in england we've got um like really
mainstream chat shows which i just don't watch
because i find them very cringy but even you know
the producers on there are talking about it um
so why do you think they've gone so mainstream and
also do you think that they're here to stay well
and non-fungible tokens yes there's countless
use cases for non-fungible tokens whether it
be concert tickets or pieces of art validation
for physical piece you know basically act as a
certificate of authenticity for physical pieces
of anything um and the list goes on obviously what
we're seeing right now in the overall jpeg market
is is bubbly you know it's got you know it's
bubbly um and i'm not any type of nft incumbent um
so you know i i have like 80 jpegs in my metamask
that's a lot of 50 i have a lot of jpegs because
i'm a degenerate and i love crypto so if anything
new comes i'm here you go take my money like let
me how are you picking how are you picking you're
not you're not just throwing money you know
i think it's important to understand too that
all the money i've put into jpegs is money that
i'm just like goodbye like this i'm not flipping
i'm not you know i haven't i haven't dropped
six figures on an ape or anything yet because
i'm just not i don't care enough i just want to
buy stuff that i think looks cool so i have jpegs
of lots of random art and just cr and just random
pfp profile pictures you know stuff like that
um you know but i think that a big reason we
see a lot of the price action is because if
you think about it is a very fragmented market
it's a very very very very low supply market
i think um openc has like 400 000 users maybe i'm
completely made pulling that around my ass but
i don't know but let's say they have 400 000
users if you take the total supply of the top
10 nft projects on openc and add them all together
there's not even enough total nfts to satisfy
25 of their active user base
across their top 10 projects so
just check this out sorry just to jump in openc
logs more than a hundred thousand users a week
new ones no i think just users a week it just
says here oh and that's their okay that's a
lot of people that's a lot of people that's 400
000 that's the number so that's a lot of people
there's not enough nfc like there's enough
nfts but there's not enough of these like
premier you know five and six and seven figure
nfts to go around and then when you add the fact
that the people who have the money to spend 100
each on an nft have the money to spend 100 on a
lot of nfts probably and so um a lot of the supply
is held by you know you'll see a project with
8 000 pieces that has a thousand unique owners
that's one that's eight pieces to every one owner
and so i think it's a supply thing too i mean
it's the most brilliant you know like supply
and demand experiment at scale because of this
because social media set it all on fire garyvee
like you mentioned logan paul whoever right um
and they're fun man like they all have fun i
think some of them are kind of fun if you're into
it i think it's kind of fun like i've had a lot of
fun playing in the space but be careful like i'm
going to lose all of my money that's in nfps right
now like just so you all know um you probably
will too so just you know buy it for the art
it's addictive though because i'm not
actually somebody that's into art at all
um but i'm really into these nft so i have no i've
never bought an nft but i've got a lot of friends
in the space yeah i've got a lot of friends in
the space and so they'll just like give me an
nft and then we'll just like i watch the price
just go up and people bidding and i'm just like
i don't want to sell even though i didn't
even pay anything for it i don't want to sell
because i don't know something about it and all
that yeah you do don't you especially if you mint
it yourself there's this user experience there's
this gamification that exists in minting nfts
gamification is hugely successful in ux like in
user experience designed for mobile apps if you
think about robinhood a company that's done it
really well blockby actually does a really good
job block fully does you know um this gamification
is what addicts people like i don't think i think
there's more people addicted to call of duty
than there probably are any hard drug on earth
it's a very addicting thing and so this this
gamification of crypto with nfts makes something
that's already got a financial incentive and i.e
can definitely motivate you in certain ways to be
more fun or at least feeling more fun it releases
dopamine in a way that keeps you kind of coming
back so you know who knows where it'll all end up
i think there's a lot more value creation coming
up and you know to that note open c with 400 000
users as the number one nft marketplace that's an
irrelevant there are no name one-off exchanges in
like random islands that have 400 000 users so um
in the crypto space so it's it's it's such a small
number when that number is 5 million 10 million
and there's still a fairly small company from
a user standpoint that supply and demand issue
really starts to compound and now you start seeing
price you know just crazy numbers potentially so
and in terms of the market right now so we have
you know nft's booming we've got bitcoin doing
something you know new highs and all this fun
stuff do you think alts are going to follow
yeah i mean they are i don't have any reason to
believe that the future won't look pretty much
like the past it kind of has always um i'm mostly
exposed to bitcoin right now i have been for a
little while because i do feel like it is kind of
bitcoin's turn again it's about that time of year
it's kind of bitcoin's time here also this is
about when bitcoin likes to do bitcoin things
yeah i bought my very first bitcoin ever in in
the month of september i'll never forget august
2017 and so forth like bitcoin loves this time of
year so um yeah i'm going to huddle bitcoin for
the most part and make a couple of other plays um
you know and then i think alts will follow and and
i hope it's not in like a blow off top manner you
know i i really like to not see 80 drawdown across
the market again i'd like to see maybe a little
bit more healthy sustainable growth i just don't
know if we're there yet but i definitely think
halls will fall 100 they always do i'm so excited
for this because i so today people on twitter were
talking about we need a name for somebody who's
who thinks bitcoin is the best form of money
the ultimate cryptocurrency yet you don't
think that everything else is a scam so that's
me but we don't have a name for ourselves yet
um we're not bitcoin maximalists um we're not [ __
] pointers but we're you know um but yeah i think
i think it's exciting because i know it's really
funny i was like should it be i don't know freedom
maximalist that doesn't work um but yeah it's it's
exciting because usually i was at one point i was
only holding bitcoin whereas now i'm a lot more
diversified and i have a nice amount that i'm
happy with but now i've got quite a few and even
i've got some really really [ __ ] [ __ ] coins so
i'm really excited so i'm really hoping the best
place to be is with lots of bitcoin and a couple
of really shitty [ __ ] coins i mean i think
that's the best market exposure that you can have
you know i i don't fault you for that we all have
our favorite but that's the kind of a part of
crypto that i love like we all have our favorite
community bags too we all have our you know that
one project that caught our high and and we went
for it and it didn't really go that great from a
price action perspective but here we go sorry
i just removed you from the stream by accident
yeah no no it was just me no we can still
hear you it's just my picture um okay so
right i want to go into entrepreneurship now um
because for those who are just tuning in now um
joel is the ceo and the co-founder of um stacked
which is very exciting yeah that's why i turn my
camera off one sec let me just say that again
that's what i was trying to do there we go
so right joel is the co-founder and ceo of um
stacked they're hiring so drop in the dm um so
let's go into this you left your job you went full
time into crypto um you know super exciting so how
did you decide that you wanted to build a business
rather than be a trader or content creator i know
that you said that you were doing a lot of drop
shipping and stuff anyway but talk me through you
know just deciding yeah this it's i know i'm an
entrepreneur because a lot of people don't know
whether they have whether they can do it and you
spoke about self-belief so talk me through that
i think if you're really first of all i think
anything can be taught so i think if you're not
inherently entrepreneurial i think you can learn
it i think you can be a successful entrepreneur
there's plenty of examples of that with people
with the right mentorship the right support system
the right financial backing whatever the case may
be um you know you can do that for me like it was
never a matter of um if i think i can do it or
not it was just like i'm going to do it like it
at the end of the day my attitude and the attitude
of a lot of successful entrepreneurs that i know
you know have al has always been it doesn't
really matter if if i succeed that's not really
the point like the point is to do what i feel
drawn to do um you know with this business like
with this with this idea and all entrepreneurs
have different businesses and everything else
you know i was creating content um because i
enjoyed talking about crypto so when i quit
my job you know i got a lot of followers
on twitter at the time and started making
friends with a lot of these other names that you
know and that was great and i really enjoyed um
sharing my opinion about stuff who doesn't and i
don't know i enjoyed having a lot of viewership
but when i really reflected i said do you want
to be an influencer or do you want to be an
entrepreneur and in 2020 2021 and in the last
couple of years it's become really sexy to be
an influencer and entrepreneur and there's
like some weird name for it probably like
an entrepreneur or something we should make one up
maybe talking about names yeah something like but
it's it's basically people who say they're
entrepreneurs because they have a merch website
or what like what like whatever the case may
be but but they're not like building businesses
what i find is if you're building and there's
different types of businesses so there's people
who can do both but what i found at least for
my business is in building my business which
now has 40 employees and you know we've scaled to
a certain i don't have time to be an influencer
like i don't have time to go on i haven't really
tweeted in weeks if you go look like i haven't
been particularly active on twitter
because it's not important to me to
be an influencer it's important to me to be in
be an entrepreneur so that had to come first so
you know it wasn't like a decision like do i
stop trying to be an influence review it was
just i was always an entrepreneur i happened to be
talking a lot of shop about crypto mostly during
the bear market and there was just a couple of us
you know talking about yeah but i always wanted to
go and do this thing and so i went out and did it
and like that's what i encourage other people if
you're wondering whether you're an entrepreneur
or not maybe you're not you're probably not that
doesn't mean you can't go learn doesn't mean you
can't go work for an entrepreneur and and see if
you like it dip your toe in and that's what i did
with grubhub i left my my stable life to go take
a chance on a tiny startup to get involved with a
vc funded company backed by you know smart people
to get experience and i spent a half a decade
there and that was invaluable to being more
of a successful tech entrepreneur now so i think
that it's interesting how you know because you're
working and you know you're building this
business and you have 40 employees you don't
have time anymore to tweet and things like that
i find that really interesting because i've been
working with a lot of different ceos to you know
try help build them and things like that and it's
annoying because it's actually part of being a ceo
you need to you need to be an influencer like you
need to have that power behind you yeah because
that's one thing which i think cz for example and
finance have really nailed um because you know
he he's obviously not an influencer but he he
has influence um and so and he he's tweeting all
the time and so i'm always saying to people i know
that you're i know that you're you're building and
this and that but you have to keep tweeting and
you know elon musk is an example yeah he's an
influencer he's an influencer and an entrepreneur
no doubt no doubt and what both you know when
you know he's also elon musk right and so
it's not that he has he doesn't make time for
being an influencer he just tweets whatever the
hell comes to his mind he's a billionaire and
a billion people follow him because he's elon
musk right like if if you know cz you
know cece's one of the rich people on
earth too you know it's it's a little bit
of a different game you know at my scale
at least to put out any content that i so on
the one hand if i really just said my mind all
the time i piss off half the people right that's
that's how opinions work like well as as someone
who's trying to get everyone to use my product
and like love the whole experience i don't want
to piss off half the audience and so i can't just
go out and be um you know i can't go out and be
like political i can't really be controversial
you know i can't necessarily chime in on hot
topics because i'm not trying to create enemies
because again business comes first and you know i
want everyone to have a favorable view of stacked
and so that means they have to have a favorable
view of the guy who started stacked so that's
a part of it so then if i'm going to put out
content that i actually care about that takes
time and right now i don't value the time enough
to do it because the roi isn't enough to do it
so i definitely agree with you i think there's
so much opportunity there and i might have to
hit you up afterwards about getting my time
better sorted out so that way i can take advantage
of the of the platform that i've built um but for
me at least in the early stages if you are someone
thinking going back to your first question about
being an entrepreneur it is really about having
conviction it's really about being able to put
your head down and say it does not the outcome
does not matter if you get too caught up in will i
sell my company for a billion dollars or will i go
bankrupt it starts to cloud all you just have to
put yourself in a position to where the finances
are sorted because you know that's something that
i think if you're not financially healthy it's
gonna be really hard um and then just go for it
you make such an interesting point about the
politics and things that you can and cannot say
um because it's such an issue that i think a lot
of entrepreneurs are trying to find that balance
um i think you know if you're an influencer more
say look let's say it's like um let's say it's
like a spectrum and you're an influencer here
i should make my hands a bit closer you're an
influencer here and you're an entrepreneur here
the closer you are to influencer the more you're
actually able to and i think it benefits you
to say these opinions um piss people off it's
it works for politics right
but it's interesting because
right now i think that politics is creeping into
every single part of everything that we do right
you know even like identity politics gender and
this and that um you know coinbase had that whole
issue i can't really remember what it was but they
had a whole supposed racism issue i don't really
know um so i don't know like how do you how do you
deal with that you know do you did you really try
and stay away from it or do you feel you might at
some point get to a point where you know you have
to sort of like take a stand on anything yeah so
listen like when you when you turn anything into
a business it kind of reminds some of the fun like
i don't i don't love crypto the way i used to lie
i still love crypto but it's a different kind
of love i'm a very method like i look at this
it's a business right and you know it's it's
you know so it's it's not free it used to just
be me bitmex 10x yeah um it's different now you
know and so that's true too if you try to become
like if you're creating content like i was for
fun and just talking [ __ ] about crypto got a
bunch of people to follow me and then i tried
to turn it into a business because i had to
do that to pay the bill like you you're in this
position as an influencer if you go full time i'm
saying if you're like this is what i'm going to
do well you got to make money well to make money
you kind of got to sell out you either got
to sell ads you got to sell ref you got you
know whatever um so nothing like crazy no like
crazy ico scams or anything but taking you know
uh shilling a referral link or what and what what
it came down to is for me like i just hated all of
it i was like this is all stupid i don't think any
of the like i don't want you to use my ref link to
trade on bitmex because like you probably like
that's not you lose money disingenuous it just
wasn't for me personally right and also keep in
mind i'm not an anonymous twitter person yeah
and some of the biggest names that you see
ruffle the most feathers and get the most
hyperbole really you know going on are people
who are hiding behind the veil of a cartoon
account which is fine and i actually i'm very
close friends with a lot of them and totally
understand why why they are not thoughts and i
totally support their decision to not be doxxed
but as a result they don't suffer the same
personal consequences for their opinions uh like i
will as a public-facing ceo of a of a well-backed
tech business like i i just can't play the same
politics so i think if you're gonna do it you just
gotta be genuine you just and so for me me me not
tweeting for a week is genuine sometimes and then
you'll see sometimes if you follow me like i'll go
off for days like i'll just i'll tweet 100 times
a day for a week and then i'll disappear for a
month that's just me that's just genuine that's
just right now i care and tomorrow maybe i don't
care and today i love your nfp tomorrow i don't
probably care about it that's just me being just
me being me so you just gotta be yourself i think
i mean you just can't go out there and like try to
i don't know fake it like you'll get ripped apart
oh absolutely yeah especially crypto twitter it's
toxic and we know who we're talking about there's
fakers and there's larps right there's like people
we and we know and the community knows and
sometimes i wonder if the larp themselves
knows that we all know because sometimes they
tweet like like they're acting like we don't know
it's true it's true and you
really do get ripped apart so
you know integrity um is essential but
in terms of just building this business
because i'm sure there are a lot of people
listening thinking you know i don't want to
be an influencer i want to build something that
people can actually use um what are some of
the biggest challenges that you came across
and also challenges that you didn't expect
well i'm building a tech product so the challenges
were largely people like talent specific like
finding the talent to build a tech product
um and then obviously you know solving the
problems in tech and i'm not natively tech i'm
a self-taught front-end web developer i don't
know anything about pretty much anything so um
yeah the challenges are i'm not a finance guy
and i'm not a tech guy and i'm going to build a
finance tech company that's a challenge in and of
itself so how do you solve for that you surround
yourself with people who are just gigabrains
so sam bankman freed um the earliest supporter of
stacked we were the earliest supporters of him and
alameda and ftx and we built a good relationship
with that whole team as a result and that's been
invaluable the same goes for like countless other
connections that we have in crypto the the entire
breadth of our success is due to our friends on
twitter you know people who have like shared our
product our investors like sam and and jump cap
you know other like really really great investors
and big announcement coming soon on that front
um and just a great network hiring people like i
am just good at like bringing people together i'm
pretty much crappy at every individual thing and
so if you understand that as an entrepreneur like
where your strengths are and you plug in people
in your weaknesses then you have a real shock at
doing something but it's you know it is kind of a
team after like you're going to have to reach out
very likely and start building that network if you
want to have a real shot at like you know building
something it's a huge challenge that's so spot on
you know surround yourself with good people that
you can add value to and they can add value to you
you know it's a good give and take relationship
is so important but it's actually really hard
i know for me you know i find it i i took like
a huge dive into crypto and lost honestly a lot
of friends because they didn't get it it's a whole
new mindset and so it's very difficult to surround
yourself with not just like-minded people but you
know intelligent people and that it just works
with so even hiring people is hard so you know how
do you go about finding good quality people yeah
so this i don't know how this will come off
to the audience but like yeah it is hard
like that's why most people won't succeed at
what you're doing or what at what i'm doing
because it is super hard and it takes a long
time like think about all the hard work you put
in to get to 150 000 followers on twitter and
crypto mostly during a bear market that's hard
like and so that i want to make sure that no one
listening is going to be mistaken for the fact
that there may be an easy way to get rich
trading to get rich being an entrepreneur
a content creator an influencer or whatever it's
just first and foremost understand if you're
listening to this because you have inspiration
to be full-time and crypto or an entrepreneur
understand first and foremost it is freaking hard
and and it will test you in ways that i that i
cannot begin to to to make a parent to you how do
you get over it when you mention hiring particular
try really hard uh ask people go on
in email dm phone call google youtube
find recruiters in my case i i went to my
board you know who are again people who i
surround myself who have business career hey
give me some great recruiting companies i don't
have any recruiters in-house and i need to hire
rockstars that's what they did they introduced me
recruiting companies you write the check they send
the candidates and then you figure it out you know
and so it depends on what stage you're at but i
think embracing the fact that it's super hard and
that there isn't maybe just one way to go about
solving for that is part of being an entrepreneur
like i can't give you the roadmap because it's so
different for everybody all i can tell you is it's
going to be really hard and you'll probably fail
and if you still go for it after hearing and fully
understanding that you're probably going to make
it because that alone saying like hey it's really
hard you're probably going to fail that gets
that weeds most people out yeah yeah you're right
see myself out so i don't know you just gotta
you gotta want it in some kind of way or you
gotta be super lucky like do not get me wrong
there are people out there who just in spite of
them have just fallen into absolute you know
gold mines and businesses and that's great
you know god bless them yeah is there anything
that you would do differently or any mistakes
that you've made that haven't added value in the
long term oh sure sure sure um yeah i tend to be
like ask alan or or steven or any of my guys on
my team like i tend to be um pretty like like
i'll get it i'll get an idea and it's like let's
let's do it and let's start like moving towards
it before it maybe is fully flushed out and then
it's like yeah maybe and so i tend to move maybe
too quickly that's definitely a weakness sometimes
it can be a strength definitely but yeah sometimes
as a weakness um but you know there's tons of
things i would do differently like in hindsight
we've made bad hires we've made bad we've made
some really good decisions i think on like the
investment side of our business but yeah you make
some bad hires you make some poor product choices
you go with the wrong vendor countless stuff you
know um that i would ultimately do differently um
i never did a token for stacked i think that's
a good thing no yeah in hindsight i wouldn't do
that differently back then but now that i didn't
do it back then and i have the resources to maybe
do it correctly now it's something that i maybe
will explore so i don't i don't know if we can
drive real value to users and be compliant then
definitely something we'll explore but i don't
think i regret not doing a token either even
though it would have surely put tens of millions
of dollars in the pockets of like all the early
people here but um yeah well my thing with tokens
well as you can say like my thing with tokens is
i often find there's a lot of companies that often
have a token for the sake of having a token just
to keep you in the ecosystem that really annoys me
though like as a user i don't really that doesn't
really add any value to me that's like 95 percent
of tokens they have a token just now yeah that's
why i said i'm glad you don't have a token yeah no
it's a crowdsource it's a crowdsourcing mechanism
that's what i'm getting at is like if i were to do
it i'd do it right like if it's a crowd if it's
a if it's a funding mechanism i'ma let you know
like this is a funding mechanism i'm not going to
try to hide it behind the veil of some you know bs
white paper that's going to say it's going to do
this yeah there's very few examples of tokens that
are not tokens just to be tokens and so i totally
agree that's why we haven't done it because
um that just wasn't part of our mission and
keep in mind too we're a us-based like regulated
we're trying to build a very specific product
for a very specific user so when we look up
we're inspired by block five by m1 finance by
coinbase um none of whom have tokens exactly so
um for me and for this business today that's you
know that's where we're at but like i said because
of the product we're building and the ecosystem
we're building in especially on the decentralized
version of stack that we're working on
there may very well be a real utility for
a token and we'll be excited to explore that yeah
as long as there's real utility and real value
for could you imagine like a decentralized stack
right stacked is a great product you still have
to connect to your centralized exchange in order
to use it right and but we would love for you to
also be able to connect your metamask wallet and
and hold or your or your ledger right and actually
hold your keys and still be able to take advantage
of those tools well in doing so we'd have to build
some type of you know blockchain solution and
in doing that there may be again a real a real
need for a token so stay tuned you know stay tuned
all right so just finally what advice would you um
would you give to people um looking to go full
time looking to potentially build um you've given
a lot of advice but just one sort of main overall
to to end the conversation i you know surround
yourself with good people uh like i said find a
find a partner maybe not even one that's a friend
when me and my business partner went to
business together we weren't friends we
weren't like not friends we were just a point
we just met we were just like acquaintances
yeah well we've become brothers right like we've
become very close but so you know find people who
are speaking your same language that that can
help your your mission um and have conviction
um you know you you have to really believe
it in your core and be like moving towards
you know something that's inspiring to
you you know for us it's reinventing
really the way that you know retail investors
interact with long-term crypto investments
active indexing you know tax loss harvesting
like really bringing traditional finance
tools to crypto because it's needed that that
drives me it's something i'm passionate about
so you should do that and and then you'll probably
find it if you go out and try to start a business
with the sole purpose of making money in my
experience it can be harder to make money
if you go out with the purpose of solving a
problem in my experience if you solve that
problem the money will follow because people
are willing to pay for the solution but if you
have money driving your motivation it will
cloud how you go about the solution because
you may decide the solution requires x y or z
that it that maybe it really doesn't and so just
again try to be like really clear in your mission
and your purpose and what you're working towards
and go into it with that mindset and then fail
forward fail fast and feel forward if you feel it
you know if you screw it up drop it if it's
wrong that's a tweet i should tweet that yeah
maybe i will you should tweet that you should
do that once we get off you should tweet um
what did you just say no before that you're like
something it's something fast and then fail fast
and fail forward yeah yeah tweet that see that
once we get off okay you want to fail fast you
want to fail forward that is my advice there
you go it's good um yeah and you'll be fine yeah
even for those who aren't necessarily um
building a business like you did but are
um you know just trying to go on their own
whatever it is um having that conviction and also
putting value before money is so important um and
then i guess we'll just just add this bit at the
end here it's also knowing when to say no um and
understanding that actually it's okay to turn down
money if it doesn't add to the final goal so you
have to know okay what is my goal is my vision
if it doesn't add to that turn down the money
otherwise it's a waste of time and it won't sit
right with you um and your integrity you know with
with us pre-revenue pre-user pre-money bootstrap
bear market bitcoin three thousand dollars we
had someone offer to buy half our company for
seven figures invest seven figures for half the
business at a time where we needed it desperately
at the absolute worst part of crypto history
um it didn't align you know at a higher level
with our with our vision uh and we turned that
money down and i as a result didn't pay myself
and neither did my founder for another six
months um you know and in hindsight that
decision saved me literally tens of millions of
dollars so um yeah i think you're 100 right know
when to say no like know when to again have that
conviction and understand what your mission is
um you know and that's really the best you can
like and at the end of the day i i've started
saying this more recently but i'm very guilty as
an entrepreneur of over indexing myself and like
over like working too hard and taking it way
too seriously and putting an 80 hour wait and
like just going crazy crazy crazy i'm obsessive
compulsive and a lot of entrepreneurs are the
same way but i have to remind myself sometimes a
colleague of mine someone who works for me said
this the other day he was hey it's just a job like
at the end of the day stacked it's just my job
it's an important job that is you know has all
this story and has all this you know risk reward
but it's just like at the end i got my wife you
know you know i got my family i got my friend
and like so when when you when you tackle this
full-time thing whether it's content creator
entrepreneur whatever just remember like at the
end of the day like try if you like trying to take
it too seriously like still live your it's just
your it's just a job you know what i mean sure
yeah it's true where can people find you
and how can they get involved in stacks
well we'd love for you to check out stacked
we're launching aggressively in the us we've
only recently started supporting coinbase and
ftx so more and more products coming there but
if you're especially if you're a normal ftx
or a buybit user uh stacked is huge for you
uh you can go to tristact.com and you can just
follow me at bitcoinbirch on all platforms if you
if you want i don't talk as much as i used to you
know i know you're going to get me back into it
so we'll rock and roll i will do i will do guys go
follow joel on twitter um and yeah joel thank you
so much for coming on it's been so interesting i
love to talk um entrepreneurship business because
it's you know everybody wants to achieve more a
lot of people want to achieve more and it's very
difficult sometimes to have these conversations
um with people in your immediate vicinity so yeah
thank you so much for coming on um and sharing
your your experience with us anytime thanks for
having me as always and guys thanks so much
for tuning in please don't forget to hit the
like button and subscribe on youtube so you never
miss a video i will see you next week alright bye